- I have a breathing problem.
My doctor would not
- I work for Costco
- let me wear a mask
- and I'm asking this member
to put on a mask but
that is our company policy.
- Anyone harassing me
about a mask.
- I don't wear a mask
for the same reason
- You are guys are
- I don't wear underwear.
- violating federal law.
- Things gotta breathe.
- There's no reason to be
walking around with a mask.
Fuck your mask I'm done with it
The media asks: you run with it
Restricting citizens'
airways over the airwaves
Good luck with it
Land of the free, home of the brave
If that's the case, we'll show our face
And ignore those stores
with the signs at the door
By law we can turn you away
Pah, not today
Last time I checked the USA
Had rights for the citizens
Right where we're living in
Rights that were written to keep us safe
From federal government overreach
Holiday weekend, close the beach
Virus comin' from overseas
So wear this until you overheat
Don't even get me started
on freedom of speech
Our freedom's already under seige
From blue state heathens
seizing a free man's liberty
Sounds like treason to me
So fuck your masks
Fuck your science
And fuck being told what to do
I'm speaking truth you look like fools
Ain't nobody mask for the flu
Besides, its bad for my asthma
And I'm asking what comes after
Today it's mask up, don't visit grandma
Tomorrow I'm wearing a hazmat?
This virus: exaggerated
Vaccine: Bill Gates'
Face masks: mandated
Freedom: asphyxiated
(mumbling)
- Chris, Chris mate, you
need to take the mask off.
(mumbles)
We can't hear a word you're saying.
- It undermines the message.
- I get that it undermines the message
it's just that no one can
understand a fucking word.
The only way we're coming
out the other side of this
Is if everybody does their fair share
That includes you selfish individuals
Saying 'I want fresh air'
Let me rid you all of your self delusion
All I hear is 'we don't care'
Fox news anchors expressing their views
You know more than a doctor, yeah?
Now, the president he set a precedent
When he elected to keep his
face clear of a covering
Hesitant 'cause he'll be greeting kings
And masks just get in the way of governing
Evidently he don't even
give a shit about healthcare
Unless he the one suffering
Negligent leadership, arrogant ego trip
This is the reason that we aint recovering
I saw that bloated blowhard
when he gave conferences
With dumb remarks
Out the way, let Fauci start
Trump, you're a joke like Groucho Marx
Never forget that your ass was impeached
Adderall leads to you slurring your speech
Peach faced prick, oughta
practice what you preach
And reach for a liter of bleach
Don't even get me started on the governors
Opening bars while cases are rising
Florida spiking, Southerners dying
Ron couldn't give a shit? Not surprising
Ignoring the patterns,
the curve to be flattened
The public just fodder for cannons
They're letting this
happen, in maddening fashion
And you fucking fell for it Karen!
Oi! Watch my lips when I speak to you,
'Cause I know that you think I'm a sceptic
Point to a study that's peer reviewed
That show these are even effective
Besides, if I got the right to bear arms
Then I got the right to bare skin
And of course you wanna wear a mask
You ain't got no chin!
It's the smallest of
prices to pay to save lives
It confuses me why you'd refuse it
I'm uncomfortable, not even vulnerable
And other misguided excuses
It shouldn't be a matter
of a lack of a mask
Means you support the commander in chief
You should wear it because you care
Or British and ashamed of your teeth
You're blowing it out of proportion
Making it sound like apocalypse horseman
Hypocrite, no choice
when it comes to a mask
Pro choice when it comes to abortion
Why the hostility, violence and misery?
I pity your negative worldview
This is a country that's
founded on liberty
And there ain't no mask on a statue
There should be one on you though
Or is your empathy too low
Do you not give a fuck about anyone
Unless it's someone you personally know
The sooner you cover your mouth
When you're out of the house
then the sooner it stops
Do that and it won't be
too far in the future
That we can all take our mask off